[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to there's
just something about nostalgic fantasy
books whether they make good film
adaptations or whatever Eragon was
there's always a part of us that has to
see what the cinematic version of the
most imaginative tales look like and
clearly the best director for a trippy
sci-fi Mindwarp about children traveling
to different worlds would be one who
specialized in films about prejudice and
race relations well that turned out
exactly what we got
[Music]
being immediately an already difficult
book to adapt with one time tries to be
that artsy kids film and to open up your
mind but instead turns out to be that
artsy kid that tries to open up her mind
with his ultimate interpretation of
Donnie Darko yeah you all know that
asshole they made a movie like him based
on the only kids fantasy books you
remember being more jesusí than narnia
the adaptations for this novel have
often been underwhelming and this
version is not underwhelming but how do
I put it remember that very pompous
ending to American Beauty where they say
you don't understand our film but don't
worry you will imagine that for two
hours but is there anything about it
that worked I mean without the use of a
slowly becoming legal substance well
let's take a look in more detail this is
the unsurprisingly bizarre but
surprising in the way it's bizarre
wrinkle in time the film opens with
Chris Pine and Mel Gibson's beard
showing his daughter Meg the ABCs of
pretentious speeches is always there
even if you don't feel it I want you to
remember that when you read the reviews
for this movie this is are enough gee I
wonder if that speech about love means
he's gonna disappear I'm gone dad later
tomorrow marks the four year anniversary
of the disappearance of massive
scientist dr. Alex Murray there are
still no leads in the case but perhaps
the biggest mystery why can two kids who
can have screens in front of them
literally through breathing listening to
radio
as a pop song indicates mega sad and
often me followed by mean kids who say
such terrible things as Jaime you get it
you can call me every variation of the
c-word you like but say hi to me you
better expect this and return it
hi Megan oh hi Marc trust me you'll be
seeing few high marks in this
[Music]
yeah we made that on our way to make
father Terabithia kid for losing his
best friend our gang is called the plot
devices anyway what do you make him fun
at her for it this is the kid asking for
it and she never mixes my medications at
all also unconfused
who's he talking about being awkward and
funny-looking the way meg is supposed to
be awkward and funny-looking oh god yeah
by Disney standards what a dog that she
is only on the cover for magazines
instead of five when will everybody
learn that beautiful people are
beautiful people she gets sent to the
principal for introducing the bully to
basketball because that's a problem the
principal would deal with and he tries
to give some advice you can't keep using
your father's disappearance as an excuse
to act out odds are he's not coming back
oh this is why I got the most
emotionally crippling principal of the
Year award don't worry things will make
more sense when you get hung up boy your
house is so warm you've done a wonderful
job keeping the darkness out call me
mrs. whatsit I will call you anything
you like as long as you don't touch my
bathing suit area don't worry my friend
I caught her stealing sheets guys she's
harmless
anybody who breaks into a house and
touches kids like that isn't that
harmless she is on a list have I ever
been wrong he might be Charles Wallace
oh I highly doubt that he's one of the
greatest minds in recent history
his personality is on par with man dark
but still smart cookie I do hope you
leave on a line more up your ass than
your toilet paper coat I'm really
confident in my weirdness which means
either escape from a place with bars on
the window I'm really cool I'm not
really cool I random boy from school
want to be a character Oh tell us
whether you're talking aren't you
what are you doing here I don't know I'm
introduced 15 minutes in I had no lines
and I had nothing to the story but I do
give this punchable look of whimsy every
five minutes so what do you say Calvin
you want to come with us
why not so ever wonder if that crazy cat
lady down the street was as insane as
you thought she was love without love is
like a tree without blossoms or fruit
Gibran Lebanese this is mrs. who played
by Mandi coming
Charles seems to have met her before and
explains how she only speaks in
obnoxious quotes he's just a ball the
past language so when she needs to think
she keeps and uses other people's words
oh that's evolving past language huh
because it kind of sounds like you're
just not smart enough to come up with
your own words so your use of famous
quotes calendar to give the impression
you're above everyone else
the wound is the place where the light
enters you Rumi person hey how about
this quote you do not need to quote
great men to show you all one I realized
the irony I'm using a quote to get that
across but I don't think she's smart
enough to realize that soon we tired her
out she was really tired it's tough
being that pretentious 24/7 they go back
home where Calvin gives more inspiring
faces is that his role as they discuss
how her death suggested that space
travel can be done through the right
frequency from your mind rather than
enduring the oppressive rules of time
and space we could wrinkle it
we don't need rockets we don't need
spaceships all you need is to tap into
the right frequency you just need your
mind you have to be really long-winded
and act like your superior above
everyone else speaking of which where's
Oprah
[Music]
finally a size and image that
encompasses all of Oprah's ego why be
president when I can be God your father
has done an extraordinary thing no human
has ever traveled so far out in the
universe I was thinking about putting
him on the cover of my magazine just
giving you'll be me again we heard a
call out in the universe a human call
they say the call must have come from
her father so they're there to help find
it we must find him as soon as we can
are you up for it depends will I also
look like Tina Turner exploding it to
Lady gaga
just have to find the right frequency
and have faith in who you are okay that
last part is bullshit but Disney really
likes to throw that in very much so
tester you're scary enough far away I
don't need to see you up close the foot
feels the foot when it feels the ground
Buddha Nepali shut up or I'll stab you
in the face with a soldering iron walk
it Joe Dirt they journey to one of your
desktop backgrounds as they get busy
trying to find her dad or they look
around
[Music]
the online tea Oprah smiles at your
enchanting waste of time oh don't think
he pass up a whimsical face you should
talk to them everyone knows that flowers
are the best cost birds in the entire
universe I think even hippies would
watch this saying get a job can you help
us find him hey that's funny I speak
finger they say her father is just north
of avatar Park so what's it suggest they
travel on her once she changes into sexy
vegetable gremlin Tucker
American it shouldn't die everybody
everywhere so they ride the Cabbage
Patch stingray and are so blown away at
Oprah's magnificent Oprah Nastase imp
Lee have to touch her that sounds like a
joke but it is all too laughably real
[Music]
oh my soul is filled with the need to
hand out cars to mask my insecurities
perfection lives in the cheeks of
paradise this is where we grow the Jolly
Green Giant testicles what do you think
he got that voice from singing lessons
but uh-oh they lose one of their flops
oh no I'm gonna die flowers catching
though and they show them the evil that
distracted their flight
it's called Camazotz known simply as the
it I know I could come up with a better
jump I love any excuse to play that
cliff what do we do love looks not with
the eyes but with the mind Shakespeare
British the ability to speak doesn't
make you intelligent
the only good quote from Phantom Menace
they traveled to Mordor Stonehenge where
they come across the happy medium which
sounds like a New Age kid show on Bravo
well you obviously don't understand the
importance of ballots well not as much
as you use that stuff double we are
looking for men who's lost in the
universe well this one popped up right
away but give me some more information
they say they all have to think of makes
father in order to locate him but she
can because she doesn't see how that'll
help
well they don't understand how thinking
about him is going to help us find him
now flying vegetable ladies and ten
story talk-show host that I can believe
but they give my father
I just don't follow they explained that
they need her father to fight the it
from corrupting mankind and that gives
her the courage to find him with just
the happy medium wait what happened to
needing everybody they see the father
figure now teleporting but got captured
by the it so they decide to go back to
earth to figure out a plan makes will to
find her father is too strong though and
it redirects them to where the it is a
place where the Three Stooges have no
power so they have to leave you'll
encounter things you think you know but
you don't
it's a place to be suspicious now this
is especially disappointing because in
the book apparently the revealed to be
centaurs but my guess is heavenly Oprah
would die before being seen as something
such ungodlike but I of course would not
want to rob you of such an image so here
it is though present are we can barely
tester ourselves we must continue on
without us you must find your father
times like this I really love my job
[Applause]
[Music]
so the ax tries to chase our heroes down
but they escape via Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull fridge and try to figure
out what to do next how did you do that
whole thing with the log just a physics
thing that's a physics thing they find a
neighbourhood but quickly put together
it's a little too Pleasant village
darling
time for dinner are you lost children I
bet you're hungry
we're having fresh you tonight I have
roasts and potatoes and cakes of all
sorts packet e come on we've just been
told we're in a place of pure evil what
could go wrong
next will be telling me that gingerbread
house is evil thanks word I'd have all
sorts the fairy cakes of all sorts guys
swords the neighbourhood turns into a
beach once again trying to trick them
who are you guys the man seems to know
who they are and possesses Charles to
follow him thanks for everything
you put him right to us I'm beginning to
think case of all sorts are clones of
limited options
welcome to Central Central Intelligence
please he is dangerous shut up yeah shut
up Meg
did I really just hear that they
honestly just said shut up Meg shut up
yeah shut up Meg okay
thank you says only a merit I before
Disney would do this joke better than
Fox's shut up me yeah everybody lost
that day so bad enough the stranger has
turned into a puppet Club Med host and
Calvinist duck in permanent mark
wahlberg happening face what no but
charles is amazingly misdirected acting
now has an evil spin as his possession
forces him to talk more like a James
Bond villain that's so like you to try
to come to the rescue
isn't it Calvin always so helpful overly
carry pathetic honestly I can't decide
whether or not this makes things more
awkward or if it just fits right at home
with his performance watch this kid
could give - a run for his money he's
gone he's not gone I don't see you he
suddenly turned from the most annoying
part of the movie to suddenly the best
clever perhaps if you push back my
bedtime I won't have to push back
you're dead time make uses the glasses
though to find a secret entrance to
where her father is look out a genuinely
emotional scene
[Music]
even though this is a very touching and
well acted moment I have to admit I do
kind of what Porky Pig to jump out and
say that's all folks for a number of
reasons the movie would stop so the
father is back but that doesn't subtle
down Charles is acting at all I'm
underwhelmed I can see the witnesses of
any soul I take your soul so desperate I
want to bundle you up in a toy and call
you my little Hitler no cakes of all
sorts is worth this Charles throws them
in a dark realm where the it tries to
tempt Meg to join him oh my god she's
moderately better-looking honestly I
kind of think she looks better how she
is she of course resists and make tries
to snap Charles back to his quote normal
self
don't make me somewhat impressively
shake you in its mildly annoying it of
course works in charles's back as the
missus returned to give support some of
our best warriors have come from Earth
this is where we leave you to become
warriors on earth hmm
do you mean actual layers are getting
offended to feel superior on social
media she returns home in a beautiful
yet weirdly long transition home and the
family is once again whole now I might
have messed up a few parallel dimensions
it's a long story but I think I have
tribal blood in me now
huh I guess we're cool now for no reason
let's go eat something cakes of all so
what is your deal I couldn't have done
it without you windowsill and that was a
wrinkle in time all the right
ingredients for the wrong meal with the
wrong cook in a weird way I can see this
being one of those trippy movies that
kids look back on years later as a means
of opening up creative ideas but unlike
other films that did that like say
labyrinth or Fantasia this isn't going
to hold much value for adults visually
it's nice and it's got some interesting
concepts I'll even go out on a limb and
say the performances from everybody are
good if they were just in more fitting
movies Charles is acting could be great
in a kid's action film Calvin's acting
could be great in a Spielberg style
fantasy even the missis's could work and
maybe a fairy tale type genre but with
the exception of the main lead and her
father who really do hit their marks
perfect everybody seems like they're
giving their all just in the wrong
project because of that it's a little
entertaining and just how misguided it
is I don't know if that's the director
or Disney or whatever but it's a
fascinating lock up my guess is none of
the people who worked on this or kind of
have trouble finding work in the future
it just has to be a project that matches
their talents better as is though this
is a craziest journey through what the
hell's build that didn't make me think
but it did make me smile
five minutes tops a critic if you'll
excuse me there's a certain season
around the corner I need to get excited
for that's right matt'll wait this first
[Music]
[Applause]
haters of all sorts
hey everybody Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out have you been watching
the news you know that the California
wildfires have been not only destroying
so much property so much forest but
they've also been destroying so many
lives it's really really destroyed so
much and that's why this week we are
doing the California fire foundation
this is a charity set up not only to
help the families and the victims of
this terrible fire but also help the
firefighters and their families as well
people putting their lives on the line
so hard so much to stop this terrible
terrible tragedy going on it's by the
time this video is coming out I think
it's still going on so please please
definitely go show your support and just
give whatever you can to this charity
because it's just eating up so much and
man they just they need help man they
need our support and just give whatever
you can definitely click on the link and
see what you can do to help take care
you